thank you
[Music]
so you guys know that uh the try guys
had to let go of Ned Fulmer because he
cheated on his wife of 10 years
Ariel I heard about that an employee of
the company oh that's why I don't know
oh I don't know that much I said oh
that's why well I totally get it I get
it because I was like I was like that so
I was like wait isn't that like your
personal life what does it have to do
with the company but I'm like oh but
it's within the company it's within the
company and it's it's kind of also
against the established ethics that they
sort of like they're known as being like
really good dudes like and he's always
talking about his wife on all their
content then they're massive creators
and you know even if you don't uphold a
certain reputation you're already
expected to you know at that level like
you can't really get away with a lot of
[ __ ] right yeah so um because the try
guys over the four of them and uh if you
don't know who they are they're an
offshoot from BuzzFeed I don't know if
you remember when they were back on
there doing different like they try
stuff exactly we're gonna do 50 push-ups
I'll let you guys know if you should
they're absolutely awesome and then uh
what happened is
married dude Ned Fulmer he was caught
like actually like out in public by like
uh some other tick tockers that oh
they filmed it no disguise
publicly for them to do it it kind of
threw try guys into this spiral of like
you know there's so many Financial
aspects that come into play when you
have to repair and like you know you got
to do a review of a person and it and at
that level of where their company's at
it's not a [ __ ] easy thing to go
through yeah they probably Gotta Buy
each other out and [ __ ] too it gets
complicated it's weird yeah so they had
to let him go
um and it's not clear yet whether or not
Ned Fulmer's divorcing his wife they
don't know yet
um they uh they have said recently that
there's just no way he's coming back it
doesn't matter but without going into
all the info surrounding it there's
enough videos on every Creator's thing
about this let's talk about what we
would have to do ethics wise that would
get us kicked out of JK oh my God it'd
be so hard we'd have to do so much to
get kicked out of here right now because
we're pretty like forgiving and
Christian and Christians we're mostly
Christians that's what Christian's all
about right Christianity is all about
forgiveness and love and stuff like that
Christian companies Christian company it
starts with a joke I'm thinking is JK
because they're so tolerant and
accepting I think we're pretty Christian
here
so what so we could get kicked out by I
don't know not being devil worshiping
yeah yeah that that's you can't do that
or Ouija board what kind of Christianity
allows the devil
that's true because we can always just
point at the boss and they probably did
it before we did it yeah twice yeah it's
like don't think 30 dirty thoughts like
well Joe's here yeah so there's no like
um I don't know like there's no ethics
based code of conduct here
maybe
um pedophiles maybe why is that a baby
so if one of us turns out to be a
pedophile we're out well I'm just
writing in a pencil and then we all
agreed up I'll pin it down yeah
brainstorms
I don't want to like [ __ ] put in the
concrete too fast
you don't want to put a pedophile
that's my take on pedophilia too it's
like I don't want to do a hot taste yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what if we found out
that like uh one of the guests that we
like regulated brought on not
insinuating anyone but just genuinely
somebody who will be like not here but
like kind of like brought on for time
and time uh we found out that they you
know were accused of like molestation
which has been a huge thing accused or
for sure we got evidence accused oh
because how what how the [ __ ] do we ever
get improved this guy's a lawyer all of
a sudden sure we got it for sure
it's in stone 90 of the the in within
the community that like I'm actually
like involved in type stuff like you
always hear of a q is you never go to
the courtrooms yourself you hear Word of
Mouth people are like oh I you know but
I did hear that this person or you know
them you know what I'm saying so I'm
just saying we're in like a network of
like people that sometimes are in that
type of place do I know the truth though
like they're accused but do I know the
truth yes because I would go based off
the truth so um unlike a lot of these
[ __ ] disloyal ass like YouTubers and
social media people out there where they
turn it on each other's back which one
which one same there's a lot of them
like that I would never do that I would
never do that yeah yeah
I would never for me it's like friends
first
so I would still support them they
probably can't come on the show because
we still need to [ __ ] make money
but I'm gonna text them I'ma text them
myself so they they can't come to work
that's having that's having your back
though okay you can't come anymore but
like I know the truth yeah yeah I got
your back still versus we've seen you
can't tell you there's others like
there's other [ __ ] creators that just
completely oh I don't even know who that
is you know they're just [ __ ] like
they just immediately yeah cut the whole
communication you know I mean for me for
me I'm like this everything we got going
on here is part of a bigger game right
like me and Joe
he's my brother
so if this [ __ ] killed someone
the the thing isn't like oh how do we
make JK survive the thing is how do I
keep Joe out of jail
so if on the surface Hey Joe we got a
[ __ ] movie to Mexico we'll keep
shooting this show I'll send you money
to Mexico
that's the new operation that's why it's
just not here he's my brother you know
what I mean so for me that's like it's
pretty good that's how that's how that's
how I would roll because Loyalty means
so much to me yeah so where's Joe now
is it Mexico dude opening up we told you
not to bring anything up he's opening up
a junior in a freaking Guadalajara
Correctional
what are you talking about me and Nick
just started dating
oh secretly why'd you pick me man dude
didn't put both even the hot seat oh
yeah hot seat would be good I said in
his lap where he sits on my lap what
however you guys do it usually then we
could do a third Anthony yeah dude no
one [ __ ] asked for but what if
there's all this drama with their you
know with their significant others
always banging on the door being like I
know they're in there that's good drama
that gets viewed that's a good job what
if we like we we're just real [ __ ] to
each other on the on the show and it
makes for bad content oh no
that's not good and I'm like Anthony got
a weak dick can I just say that oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah and I just call him out
that makes it was a pretty good content
in these conditions
so basically if it uh affects our
performance or affects the quality of
our brand which is in this example right
that literally goes against like code
and morals that was very bad for them
and like you said that guy like
constantly talks about like his
significant other all of us here even
though like you know most of our
significant others are sitting right
here all of our fans like know them too
so they're also a part of that
relationship they're mainstream like
they have TV shows and [ __ ] I think
we're very lucky where our bar is like
down here yeah so it's generally
generally it's like no matter what you
do it's never gonna fall down to this
bar yeah for these guys if the bars up
here they like anything they do they
[ __ ] up it's easy so JK is just aiming
real low yeah yeah so what you're saying
we are Bottom Feeders catfish
Whirlpool costumes I heard I heard this
dude that got caught cheating he makes
like wife content yeah
yeah he monetizes his relationship and
that's why like even the try guys the
other guys said they did not have any
awareness of it and once they found out
they immediately were taking action they
just couldn't go public with that so
what happened to the other person that
was involved with the woman
um I don't know they're trying not to
put because she was getting a lot of
like unfair blame
so they're trying to kind of not focus
so much on her what's the unfair blame
like what was she wearing I think it's
fair blame because if you're in the
company and you know he was married that
dude is married you know it's not like
she was on the side going oh what you're
married yeah how could you not be aware
he's a boss he's the boss power dynamics
so it's a little bit it could be like
you know he's paying her so then she may
be you know the idea right Devil's
Advocate [ __ ] like she feels like
influenced by that and so maybe he's
pressured to [ __ ] the dude who I don't
[ __ ] know that was a big jump but I
look I hear that you know you don't know
but that's the reason why fraternizing
in the workplace with different levels
is kind of it gets a little while that's
a good idea because you never know if
it's like and the boss gets to pull
those cars right I have to have a
meeting with you you know what I mean
just like setting those situations up
you're the boss of a thing aren't you
with mainly dudes you've got to keep it
safe so yeah what's your point
where's am I right because this would be
you guys are fighting this would be
absolutely [ __ ] whack if they
just bailed in this guy because of a
public spat where he's he cheated on his
wife like that would be like I think
that's like weak ass [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] for
sure but because of the employee thing
I'm like yeah that changes the whole
thing um
for me
that makes sense yeah because that's
their company right right and it was
very sternly like [ __ ] this like they
did an announcement video where the
three of them were discussing what
happened and Eugene they have to go
public with it couldn't they just have
kept everything personal it was already
public I guess I think I think uh it was
also their choice and how they're
handling it is getting really really
great response that's cool because
they're so transparent and they're so
like yes we now we know we've done
everything we can [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
they're very like strong so does that
mean like they're hiring
can I throw my name in the Hat can I be
a loyalty what do you think you could
contribute
I can make white content too bro
[Laughter]
that's what that's what the technical
term is and the space I can try out some
stuff you know if they need uh you think
they'll find your uh inhibition to share
yourself adorable
wait hold on hold on
hold on how do you feel about this the
Loyalty thing you know Nick just wants
to hop on I have swinger style loyalty
oh okay swinger style loyalty my goal is
I'll I'll apply to the try guys and I
get some eyes over there then I bring
him back ah loyal that's what that's
like that's smart and I'll get i'll get
their trust by not telling anything
about myself I won't do any content for
them but I'll just pull them that's
really helpful during this time while
Joe's in Mexico
well I just think JK kind of done some
weird [ __ ] lately anyway with doing a
try guys video where they're trying to
cut or pay 40 percent what they try to
like we'll see what happens let's see if
these guys stay
that's a new experience Nick wants to go
pull audience here so it obviously
worked for whatever reason
foreign
[Music]
[Music]